Carl you said the last time you said
it's been 11 seasons of sunny which is
hard to grasp and one thing I've noticed
is that you guys still make Danny DeVito
do crazy often humility often humiliated
and sometimes life-threatening stunned
yeah that's true the man is gotta be
what he's gonna say 7:00 early 70s and
are you still doing that I mean you're
still what's the latest
yeah well does he ever draw the line is
he ever saying knock it off this time it
we almost killed him this year we almost
we almost we almost drowned him we we
did an underwater sequence and Danny's
incredibly buoyant like a boobie yeah so
yeah it's hard to get him down so we
really had to weigh him down to get the
shot where we're all holding hands if
there's a water landing there's a Danny
DeVito under your seat it will protect
you and when the shot was over and we
were all trying to get back to the
surface for air we all quickly got
through the water but because we weighed
him down he sort of got halfway it was
going nowhere look a panic in his eyes
of like this is the end these guys
killed me but we had only safety divers
they got him out that's that's crazy and
you pulled him out of the water and was
he upset he went straight home yeah it
was like goodbye you just shot a movie
with Ice Cube he's a great man and and
the movies called fistfight yeah we're
two schoolteachers I get him fired and
he challenges me into a fistfight at the
end of the school day I spend rated yeah
I try to war him out of it and then I I
fight the man yeah also in the movie
Tracy Morgan right Tracy Morgan the
great Tracy
right with you yes what did you enjoy
hanging out with Tracy Tracy is a joke
machine where like he'll be like hey
char-char you know what this is a mating
call and you're like great joke Tracy
but then two hours later he'd be like
chai you know what this is like a mating
call like that yeah and then 30 more
times throughout the day and and I
promise you that 30th time is the
funniest yeah yeah yeah repetition has a
breeze but he just does the same thing
over and over
that's why I'll get you far in the
business you save on right that's just
the same thing no that's just right you
gave a commencement speech yes at your
alma mater alma mater Merrimack College
that's right yeah that's a high honor
it's the highest honor yeah Harvard
Merrimack you know yeah no seriously it
was I you get did you sweat that speech
at all did you
I was terrified I watched one of your
commencement speeches and I had a full
panic attack because there's a very good
cow thank you and suddenly I realized I
should do a good job and people would
expect me to do that but it's great you
know because now I'm I am a doctor
oh yeah you got that yeah you have a yes
degree do you ever do this I got one
from yeah I got one from Dartmouth I
gave a speech there and they and now I
guess technically I'm yeah my dad's a
doctor so he's a real doctor O'Brien and
I'm like me too yeah
when do I operate no my sister has her
PhD and when I told her on the phone it
was very silent on the other go we're
like two [ __ ] from show business
like med school who needs that yeah yeah
is you me Mike Tyson and Kermit the Frog
I mean it's amazing who they give these
things we have a picture of you and you
look good I have to say you look really
good in the you look very serious
yeah well the higher you climb in life
the more ridiculous your hats become
yeah like the Pope it's true I never
thought of it that way Pharrell yeah
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]